[Music]
welcome to Good Burger homie the Good
Burger can I take your
order buckle up The New Adventures of AD
and Dex starts
now oh sorry uh The New Adventures of
Adam Dex starts
[Music]
now you think I can get a job at good
worder I'm putting a good word you Mr
Jens that's not Soap by the way it's
maple syrup
why do you guys serve veggie burgers I
can serve anything on the menu Burgers
Fri are you using a plunger to unclock
the shake machine as in the same plunger
we used to unclock the toilet uh no it
really means a lot that you came to see
me but you're my best
friend we're going to be opening Mega
good burgers in cities all over the
world from Hollywood to Hong Kong Hong
Kong is not a city it's a name of an
eight King Kong the game with the
battles ping pong the sound a doorbell
makes ding dong what we shut down this
store shut it down shut it down I don't
think you really understand you're all
fire I like that fire fire it's hot you
just got
hustled welcome to Burg can I take your
order wa Mega Corp wants to replace
everybody with robots we got to do
something going to change the world k
your
I actually no ice but there's ice here
ah no problem
dude I'll get you another
[Music]
[Applause]
one on the
E oh dude I'm glad you're
[Music]
back
he